foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
about a year ago we decided to turn a
small caravan into a food truck
we wanted to find something new and
extra motivation to do this job and then
we decided to do it for the customers
they don't want to stay in restaurants
too constraining
they'd rather communicate with people
and eat something special even if they
had to
stand in the last few months in our
country and abroad events dedicated to
street food has multiplied
the aim is to introduce and develop the
trend of the moment street food and
people have always responded with great
enthusiasm and curiosity
[Music]
we toured festivals especially in italy
we toured festivals inland switzerland
we saw what people liked the kind of
food with a nice smell a great taste we
have looked at how the vehicles are set
up the colors that are used and from
there we started planning everything
[Music]
many people are mistaken thinking that
this is a way to make a lot of money
i think it's more of a lifestyle you
experience the street the people and you
get to know real life in our neck of the
woods
[Music]
this is a movement of society more and
more people in our country want to
become independents
they are no longer satisfied with their
work in a company as a restaurant can be
because it's basically a company
where you have one or more managers you
become your own manager you make your
own investment you take your own risk
but your victories are totally your own
they're bringing their passion
the desire to show their culinary arts
street food is having an unprecedented
research
kitchens on vans and stalls are starting
to show up even on our streets
this kind of activity is tempting for
those who want to venture into the
sector the initial investment does not
exceed
50 000 francs
nothing compared to the cost and the
bureaucratic requirements for running a
restaurant
here this is a kind of activity that is
still a little
whose trends are not well defined yet
i hope that maybe at a cantonal and
municipal level some spaces will be
organized where all food trucks can be
parked and will get to work even during
the rest of the year
for the time being we'll keep attending
fairs events concerts and whatever we
can find during the summer
the difficult times will come in the
winter since we were hoping to find a
permanent location that would have
guaranteed us a regular income
the municipalities the bureaucracy there
are timelines it takes a lot of time to
have an answer which is hardly ever
positive
municipalities up until 10 years ago
only had to deal with restaurants owners
who competed with each other
now a new kind of professional has
arrived
that has a completely different
structure
and they have to decide upon the rent
some municipalities are afraid of making
mistakes and therefore they are a little
reluctant in granting
if the licences is not yet widely filled
in the rest of switzerland we are
confronting ourselves with these new
activities almost always opposed by the
professional association of restaurants
that consider us an unfair competition
geneva and fierberg started making
public spaces available for street
kitchens and some cantons are already
legislating to regulate them
street food give the possibility to eat
ethnic or regional products and not
spending much
especially for young people
and it is obvious that supply and demand
will continue to multiply
street food should be easy to eat right
so we cut it
see how you can easily cut it
i'd be a little more elegant in my food
truck and serve them on a small plate
the first free food in history dates
back to the egyptians
in alexandria the boats arrived with the
fishermen and the fish was fried on the
spot and sold to the fishermen
themselves from there they reached
greece and the romans
street food also has its admirers
they meet at viviana laportosa's cooking
classes
the cook next door loves to travel and
discover the authentic and popular
cuisine street food her research leads
us to the origins and possible
developments of this phenomenon
how do you call these
i'll show you two different styles
the classic with meat sauce
[Music]
this dates back to ancient times it
looked like a dish made with leftovers
in fact it was served during the hunting
parties of the nobles so they could
enjoy a cooked meal these are from
catania normal style rice balls with
fried eggplant
every aspect of street food is very
specific that is
i go there because i want to eat that
kind of sandwich whether it's a market
stall or a truck and i usually do a few
dishes a few but perfect and therefore
good if you are an arachini fryer in
palermo it is clear that you've always
done that if your arachini will be the
best or any way you do it so well and
you're so used to doing it you can't go
wrong
in
i take you to thailand
now how do you recognize street food
when you don't know anything you arrive
in a country and you are totally unaware
you have to understand how the markets
work what the sellers sell what do you
have to buy but when you start to hear
this noise
you can say this is papaya salad because
it's all about beating and mixing and
you can tell the siller not too spicy
but their spicy is equivalent to our
very spicy equivalent
what's interesting about street food is
that you can have the food of the whole
world at your fingertips compared to the
past i think this is precisely the big
change what we like best
there are also those who cook local
dishes but they serve them in the street
and that's what people like too
i can imagine astala polenta or a stall
soups in the winter
this happens a lot in big cities and i
think that it will reach our country at
a much wider level because as we said
before young people are the biggest
customers of sweet food
estrada
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's say that i use the little money i
had which wouldn't have been enough to
buy the chairs for a restaurant and then
i received some help from my family that
got me started i made a lease that has
helped me buy what today is my home and
workplace so to speak
about
it was my girlfriend who came up with
the idea of the truck one day when she
saw that i was a little lost she shared
her idea that i didn't embrace right
away but after a while i realized that
it could be the right thing at the right
time
[Music]
he worked in great restaurants all over
europe including one of the best in the
world the three star michelin grenanium
and copenhagen
today we find them in the markets of
locarno lucano
with personal dishes and encounter trend
when i set it up the first question was
what do you want to do and i said well i
want to change the menu every week and
he told me
you're crazy that's impossible nobody
does that
and when i hear this kind of things
that's what gets me going for me my menu
starts on thursday
and lasts four days on the second day
i'm already planning for the following
week because i have a lot of things i've
learned over the years that made me the
cook i am now and i absolutely need to
get them out as much as possible
his challenge is to stand out for the
uniqueness of the dishes he's proposing
with the techniques and experience of
gourmet food within everyone's means
while he keeps doing the job he loves
the nice thing about my food truck is
that i can wake up at 4 30 to 5 a.m and
i can work till 7am and start producing
my stuff
you can't do that unless you live
without it
you can't go there at 5am to start
working
for me this is important because i can
manage my private life and mix it with
my workouts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the taste of cartilage and veal fat is
very delicate
don't expect a strong taste in my
opinion it tastes like chicken skin
in my opinion
let's know that all
street food has become a tourist
attraction there are specialized guides
that organize walks through the markets
in the main squares of the historic
center offering the opportunity to taste
the specialties and the best fry shops
and street stalls to experience the city
as pamela residents do every day
street food is one of the foundations of
palomar mitan culture
as treaty we always say that the panel
sandwich tells the story of palermo the
same way as the cathedral the martholana
so if you visit palermo
and you don't taste its food it's like
you never were in palomo in the first
place
zeo people are you the best musaro in
pomo or in the world
in the world
because you only find the spleen
sandwich in palermo you can't find it
elsewhere in the world so
i don't mean to be arrogant and show off
but this is done nowhere else but in
palermo so i'm the best in the whole
world
this is the most famous speciality of
palermo it represents paramount much
more than the opera house
okay
[Music]
[Music]
since 1952 i've been selling spleen
sandwiches in fact you have seen a
little mastery i'm modest so i don't
want to say it myself but i'm at the
peak of the art i have to confirm that
[Music]
closely observing the dexterity and
skill of a sicilian cook is worth more
than a thousand cookbooks
we make around six kilograms a day
how many rice balls is that
a lot
[Music]
street food in palermo seems to be
resisting the attack of the big chains
the most famous american chains have
tried but they have always kept the
target of teenagers so street food
resists
it has been resisting for 2 600 years
and we hope that it will keep resisting
for a long time
what do you have there is it a sort of
an oven
it's a gas oven then i have the pen
where i heat it up
these are baked
might want to taste it once he does he's
in trouble because he'll always want to
eat it
summer or winter you're always here
this is my work my son's bread
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
the onion is so sweet
it's chopped and yes it's sweeter than
usually
[Music]
i returned to palermo for the umpteenth
time to find the most authentic street
food palermo is an open-air kitchen
there's smoke there's yelling people who
are cooking people who are eating
through this food you find pieces of
ancient history every dish tells you
about the past tell you about the arabs
a piece of bread with sesame seeds on
top tells you
that you had the a-wrap dominations and
palermo managed to blend in everything
didn't it
compared to other populations the fact
of having influences has enriched
potatoes and roasted onions
they're all blended together
you could say that yes
there's more penelope than potato
because it's made with what's left in
the pan from vanilla which used to be a
poor man's meal
and now
it's for everybody
in my opinion this must be the most
delicate right
[Music]
[Music]
what is it
with breadcrumbs
it's real innards
because onion is quite strong
and when you taste it you must drink
how come in sicilian cuisine won't
expect to find mostly fish while there
is so much meat
because in palermo we are meat eaters
[Music]
i was eight years old when i started
this job
at eight i went to school and i worked i
got married i have a wife i have
children now i'm a grandfather and i'm
still here
[Music]
no one ever complains about all this
smoke
who's going to complain only the
municipality does they don't want us to
cook in the street but since street food
starts outside it should also die
outside
[Music]
a must for lovers of the evening street
food is the historic and very crowded
even if they have always been tolerated
all these street kitchens are not really
authorized
it's bottomless and cooking is even
better
is this already curled pounded
no we don't do that
we pound other things but not the
octopus how many do you steal a day in
the evening
10 to 14 kilograms of octopus
young people are not interested in this
traditional kind of job
it's one of the ancient crafts that no
one wants to do anymore because they
would be embarrassed selling stewed
octopus they'd rather look for an office
job or sitting on a desk chair but
families can make a living with this job
these are sea strawberries
[Music]
the octopus poet
[Music]
how much do you charge for such a dish
five euros we really don't charge that
much
no matter the size
it depends on its weight but first i
look at people and if they're likable
[Music]
you come here for the typical anshi food
the stewed octopus the mixed grill the
sardines
but above all because sicilian street
food captivates intrigues and conquers
everyone
[Music]
eating street food is such a pleasant
and mouth-watering experience that today
some specialities
are also found in the restaurants
it's nice to see how the palomitan
tradition of street food reached the
restaurants in palermo itself
and then even exported abroad this gives
the possibility to those who don't know
and can't tour like a palomitan through
the city markets and streets to enjoy
street food in a classic setting like a
restaurant
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
london a dynamic city that is a sort of
a trendsetter in all fields here we
follow viviana le pertosa the cook on
the road here he has to discover what's
happening in the food trucks and on the
stalls of the english metropolis
what shall we try today your favorite
i would try the couscous actually i
already tried it this is with chicken
that one with peppers
they use fresh ingredients there are
often asians in the asian stalls and
that gives you an idea of how popular
they are because there are the tourists
who tried them but there are also the
nationals of various nationalities or in
any case of this area
thank you enjoy thank you
do you usually get something and take it
back to your office
absolutely not if it's not raining we
usually have an hour break where you
take a walk and tend to eat outdoors
in the winter you can take it back to
the office and these guys are usually
well equipped
[Music]
and surprising gastronomic offer
among the street stalls i expect to find
mainly asian and multi-ethnic
specialities but there is still space
for traditional recipes much closer to
our european palettes like the that play
can you tell me your recipe
my recipe is somewhat secret but let's
say we have boiled potatoes caramelized
and sauteed onions some ham cubes and
the rubble shown cheese
that is at the base of the recipe
it's
[Music]
i was preparing rice paper rolls with my
husband and we put a couple of
ingredients inside just immediately
looked like fun and at the same time it
was a healthy and balanced meal
they are fun you eat them with your
hands so we talked about it for nine
months and one day i resigned from
pepsico where i had a nice and important
job i was a senior product manager so
this is a big challenge for us it was a
big gamble to leave everything but this
is my new life
[Music]
on the other hand in london you can find
anything even a fusion version of the
classic gyoza pen-fried japanese
dumplings cooked by chefs who have never
been in japan
are extremely popular
it's good but i wouldn't
[Music]
a demanding cosmopolitan public and
series of dynamic people who have found
fertile ground in this field open to the
[Music]
emily if you surprises mind i'd like to
inspect if you are complying with
hygiene and safety rules okay sure can
you pass me the documents that certify
the health and hygiene requirements
they're right there
thank you very much
it's very important that the rules of
hygiene and safety for those offering
street food are the same as those for
restaurants we check that they have
about 12 documents we go from the
declaration of the methods used to the
security obligations
that they are in order we make sure that
everything as it should be
everybody gets inspected every week
because it's obvious
every time they have to install and
dismantle their kitchens and whoever
comes here to offer their products must
understand that we work in groups
there are
and if something goes wrong somewhere we
are all involved
despite appearances everything is very
organized here this market was created
seven years ago only on weekends but it
has revitalized the neighborhood in the
southeast part of london and is very
popular with people who love discovering
unusual street food we have 10 000
visitors every weekend
for the first two years there were more
street kitchens than customers the
secret is using areas where people
wouldn't normally go bringing new life
to those places along with culture and
energy today this area is vibrant with
many stores and businesses
we're the first but today there are pubs
bars restaurants and stores
it's completely different in the winter
with a temperature of minus eight
degrees celsius it's really cold and you
don't have the comfort and the heat of a
real kitchen stove which is pleasant so
i miss a real kitchen a little bit
having 10 chefs around and all that
world
so i work with my wife and yeah
we have a lot of fun
i worked in a bank in the city after
graduating in economics
i was lucky to find that place because
there weren't too many job offers but i
have to be honest i didn't like working
up at a bank
it wasn't for me
that was not what i wanted to do but i
kept seeing these nice guys around that
came into the street with their stove
one day i saw one of them selling 300
meals in an hour
i looked at his menu and i said to
myself this guy is making a lot of money
while at the bank we weren't doing as
much so i resigned and i started selling
tea and i learned a lot mostly what not
to do
today i organize and manage different
markets like this in london and i
wouldn't like to do anything else
this is a family
[Music]
competition and selection are very
strong
groups of vendors have found a solution
that is setting the standard for getting
permits and finding privileged areas
like this in the financial district of
canary wharf
they come together in an association
such as a curb group which runs many
markets daily in the city and selects
its members based on quality of the
offer
because we work as a collective we
present ourselves all together
as a group not as a single vendor herbs
promote us make us know and most of all
manages to place us in these incredible
locations
impossible to find a place like this by
myself
an indian sandwich far away from india
reviewed by timeout magazine as one of
the best in london we set off
independently
because they have very high standards
for the quality of street food we
convinced them to let us join the group
after they tasted our dishes
we took them to the managers of some of
their markets we explained our
philosophy our brand who we are and
after a month
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
every day he moves around the market of
curb with his van and he also has a
small stand in a crowded multi-ethnic
market of camden town
a lot of people came here all over the
world to learn and copy our models
in london street food was left
relatively free to develop so they want
to replicate the model it's a wonderful
thing
all over the world i think it's a
wonderful thing
it's lovely
all this pork
we put all this book
okay uh so we um
i studied as a chef in new york
i started as a chef in new york
i worked in many restaurants private
clubs then i met my wife
in london i worked at the hotel ritz for
six months then in the kitchen of the
royal opera house then i became a chef
for big business managers
and that's when i started to find my job
unbearable i did it just for the money
and not for the pleasure of cooking so i
decided to do something different
i didn't even know that street food
existed i did some research and i found
out that there was nobody here who was
doing greek street food
greek yogurt cucumbers garlic salt
vinegar and fennel pollen
that's the best of compliments
next stop is the spitalfields market
where every day hundreds of people line
up in any weather conditions to get a
tasty lunch from the wide variety of
dishes
[Music]
in london
it congratulations that the london lunch
break is now synonymous with street food
but looking for quality
with six to seven pounds you can go to
any other pizzeria sit at the table and
have pizza here they take it with them
or they fold it mostly italians
or they eat it standing somewhere and do
something like that it means they really
appreciate our product
[Music]
he made himself known immediately for
the quality of his pizza
that he produces in two modified vans
with a real wood oven
and he is already preparing a third one
his recipe for success is mainly in the
ingredients
luckily we managed to get all our high
quality products from italy
including the wood that you see it comes
from
from naples
[Music]
since
customers it happened that the best
in a many
street food concepts became a sort of
startup that attracted the attention of
potential investors
after three or four months that we were
here in spiter fields we receive some
really great offers from investors
i always try not to accept these offers
because i'd like to grow at a slow pace
to maintain the quality of our product
something that a big company wouldn't do
using anything on their pizza
[Music]
spectacular really good sweet pumpkin
hot and spicy
salty
no he's from umbria he's from rome and
he makes chicken
he's a real nice guy over there
they make wonderful paella
street food is so captivating because in
terms of risks i think they are limited
in control because a vehicle on wheels
can be moved while a restaurant
it's stuck somewhere and you have to
make an area survey for the potential
customers but with a food truck you can
afford to try if it doesn't work the
next day you can go and try somewhere
else
[Music]
is to make the pizza fly high
and to transform every day with the
lightness of skill a simple and popular
food is undisputed excellence of the
culinary art of the world
[Music]
strolling along the trucks and the
stalls i'm thinking about the reasons
why london street food has reached such
high levels
extremely high quality varied offer
greater appeal than the classic
restaurants and above all the great
public response
the true evolution of street food took
place from simple street food to an
organized and winning system
it's like being in china the baking
tastes perfect
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the world of street food is in constant
motion and this future seems promising
in our country as well
[Music]
the future of street food is good
because actually the future is the
present we need a little more time for
certain things but i believe that we
must reach a compromise with catering
because basically we must first
understand that nobody is anyone's
competitor
there are 15 million people in manhattan
there are three food vendors and
restaurants and they're all working
so things can work out
the restaurant is clearly in culinary
arts so is the food retailer after all
we all do the same job and we are all on
the same boat if we don't cooperate with
each other it's impossible to go on
[Music]
[Music]
you